I consider myself a good person yeah you
ready you're excited I'm ready I'm
nervous my palms are a little sweaty
fear of failure I think
you
yeah I probably have done that
inevitably it's gonna take you 20
minutes to find the host so I personally
believe that in modern day etiquette we
should just do away with having to say
goodbye at parties all of my dogs and
cats have been rescued animals oh
absolutely
okay perfect we have a dog it's a pickle
but with three long ears
hi monkey oh it's a baby beagle
hi baby beagle that's like a gift from
us you can take that home with you dear
have this beagle oh I love you too yeah
I've used the men's restroom a lot um I
also believe in equal rights but the
bottom line is the toilet doesn't care
if you're male or female okay you gotta
go you gotta go
and the women it take too long
I never forget to send a thank-you note
because I don't send thank-you notes
it's not about the thank you it's about
the gift so if the person is pissy that
they haven't gotten to think you know
maybe they need to re-evaluate their
intentions you can act thankful when you
see the person but um I'm not a big
believer in thank-you notes it wastes a
lot of paper
I have a very clear-cut rule about
moving I always help everyone move
because I want others to treat me how I
want to be treated and is a great
workout
[Music]
someone else's mouth oh my husband took
my gum on our first date and that's how
I knew he wanted to bed me watch the
good place Thursdays this fall on NBC
[Music]